dena flagon is with demand for SUVs
continuing unabated since our reviewers
Sasha every car maker has to have one in
its range Fiat realized it had always
had a major gap in the family
a genuine off-roader so it took the
fremont also known as the Dodge Journey
added skid plates in front and back and
lo and behold an SUV
well almost that's what we'll be testing
today Fiats off-roader started more as a
crossover hence the name fremont cross
its bold contours set it clearly apart
from other models in the same series the
front sports redesigned bumpers with
platinum chrome colored inserts a gloss
black front grille and fog lamps the
side skirts likewise have a platinum
chrome finish
then a super Sasha a real SUV has to
have all-wheel drive even if it's rarely
actually needed the Freemont cross only
includes the feature with the most
powerful gasoline and diesel engines
he's driving a 125 kilowatt diesel and
the all-wheel drive seems to handle snow
and ice quite well on Ocean Alliance
Lake does it carry much lift the engine
is a 2 liter 16-valve turbo diesel multi
jet unit the details of the body
designer justice bull the new skirt on
the rear for instance moving on to the
interior how spacious is it I thought
being a relatively large car the Fiat
Freemont has lots of space folding the
second and third rows of seats down
produces fourteen hundred and sixty-one
liters of cargo space leaving the second
row up cuts that to 540 liters and if
you need the third row for the kids for
example you're left with just one
hundred 45 litres of space that's not
much when packing for a vacation of God
Amano who not from footsies little Dyson
today's module of scopic s slashed the
interior has a stylish look and feel
there's a top quality sound system by
alpine fitted as standard as is the
sat-nav with a 8.4 inch touchscreen
that on Fremont passengers in the second
or third row of seats can enjoy the DVD
system which costs about 900 euros extra
it'll be up to the buyer whether father
or mother to decide whether such a steep
price is worth it here in Austria the
view out the windows is definitely worth
a look and it comes for free then they
also hit some innocent oyster lies don't
see her hidden file house infants on
Devil's lips now Sasha is going to see
how the Fremont cross copes with snow
and ice the 2 liter 16-valve mocha jet
turbo diesel puts 125 kilowatts of power
through a 6-speed automatic transmission
and all-wheel drive means even
distribution to all four wheels the
cross manages the run up from 0 to 100
km/h in 11.1 seconds with a top speed of
183 km/h Fiat rates fuel consumption at
7.3 liters per hundred kilometers this
one of the SUV starts at just under
thirty two thousand five hundred euros
in Germany it scores high for a
distinctive look and exclusive equipment
features the top-of-the-line version
offers a little extra luxury what does
our car tester say about it
few thousand over fine the Fiat Freemont
cross is four thousand euros for purely
cosmetic enhancements it still may not
be a genuine SUV but it's a good car
with all-wheel drive and a powerful 125
kilowatt diesel engine buyers looking
for a real SUV will have to go to the
competition or consider something
smaller than the sizable Freemont